welcome to this video a new part new
episode of chess Giants the series that
shows great games from the past this
game is from 1973 more than 40 years old
and was played between young team on the
long time Dutch number 1 and f him
Geller yeah Geller was one of the top
players in the nineteen late 50s 60s 70s
when he was taking part in some of those
World Championship candidate tournaments
and and matches he always was yeah not
far away from getting to to the to the
very top but there was always one sort
of obstacle in his way and like Spassky
in top form or Korchnoi or one of the
other guys who just a little bit better
when it when it counted but he was some
exceptionally strong and it's very well
known that he had a hugely positive
score against Fisher which really have
almost no other player could could equal
yeah let's have a look at this game
which shows some gala and full effect d4
d5 and we get a Queens gambit declined
with Bishop e7 so a very solid opening
that nowadays sometimes is some
considered a little bit boring but get
up after pioneering the Kings Indian in
the 50s he switched back or I switched
to those kind of very classical openings
in the later stages of his career and he
had excellent results with an even he
got lots of great attacking positions
just quite remarkable let's see what
happened exactly the classical approach
with Bishop g5 here by team on castles
III and here Tim unplayed b6 the Tata
color variation orthotic Offerman
not Wanda Roeske variation the tmb and
this was the absolute main line of the
time nowadays there is quite a huge
following also 494 that the very ancient
Lasker variation which nowadays is
believed to give black quite good
equalizing chances b6 is more complex
and more interesting than the lusca um
there's a very interesting thing and
important to know Geller just one year
before this game was played in 1972 was
one of the main seconds of then world
champion Boris Spassky in the match of
the century in Reykjavik Iceland against
Fischer and Spassky played the tar take
over in the very famous I think it was
game six of the match and we follow this
game six CD 595 takes takes takes IAM
the rook see one there should be six
that's important black takes the chance
to put the bishop on e6 not on b7 you
six is the more active diagonal and it
gives some additional options later
queen a for NC 5 black uses this b6 move
as a preparation to play see five and
establish the very often called hanging
pawns if white now would take we
actually would get this kind of
structure immediately Tim unplayed Queen
a3 the main line of the time rook c8 to
cover the c5 pawn yeah and now two month
late Bishop b5 yeah those of you who
know the games of the Spassky Fisher
match might remember that this is
exactly how Fisher played in this game
six Bishop b5 was actually a novelty
there was a new move that wasn't known
at the time
Impractical play and the curious thing
is that Spassky now in the game played a
six after which Fisher captured and now
retreated back it turned out that a six
was a weakening of the pawn structure
after 97-94 Fisher had a very
comfortable position and later won a
great game after Spassky made some some
mistakes in the defense the very
interesting fact is though that the
Soviet team led by led by Geller as the
chief second they actually had
anticipated the move Bishop b5 for the
match and they had an antidote ready but
Spassky unfortunately for him forgot it
yeah he actually had known of this move
and the Soviet team had invented the
move Queen B 7 and prepared for the
match but well as mentioned Spassky
forgot forgot this idea it would have
been very interesting to see how Fisher
would responded to the move because it
now sets white a very difficult problem
in the game now Tim and took on c5 and
well at first glance it's very hard to
grasp what black is doing is he just
giving up the pawn yeah in fact he is
white can grab the pawn on c5 we look at
this in the game yeah stimmen played the
most critical move the question of ever
is is this the best move hmm probably
not the acceptance of the pawn leads to
a very difficult play for wide and maybe
the the best kind of continuation is
something like castles however after
that it is not clear what white has
accomplished with this whole operation
yet putting this pressure here and then
you don't take it black has a number of
interesting moves now one being
the move see for attending a 6b five
which makes the whole kind of
configuration look a little bit silly
black gets some nice play with as it ran
spawns yeah maybe however in a practical
sense it would be the right decision
would have been very interesting to see
what Fisher would have played after
Queen B seven but okay it didn't happen
in the match maybe you would have taken
the born as well I mean Fisher was a
very principled player but this would
have led to two very interesting
complications as we see in the game yeah
well timin took the pawn recaptured and
he grabbed on c5 at first glance if you
look at this position you have a hard
time to understand what the point of the
pawn sacrifice is to be honest when I
saw this and for the first time yeah
well many years ago when I looked at
this game for the first time I wasn't
really buying it to be honest I was
thinking no more what is this yeah I
mean anjan just one move away from
castling and if white castles the whole
thing is basically useless yeah we have
a safe King and we get an excellent post
on the four for the night however all
this is like yeah very uncommon Crete
thing going on Black has the move Knight
a six and this kind of thing that
concrete moves now set problems is them
the real story of this this game and
this some this some phase right after
the opening okay the queen is attacked
what is White's reply you cannot move
the Queen anywhere without blundering
the bishop besides to c6 you can go to
c6 that's possible but let's have a look
what happens after Queen c6 yeah black
chasm has a strong reply he can trade
and then it's very important to play the
right move look b8 is by far the
strongest look see 8 is less convincing
as Bishop a4 and Bishop d1
kind of defense the whole thing wide
really will quickly get in castles and
Bishop b3 for example and consolidate
matters it's not as soon as dangerous
also there sometimes it's a simple idea
to return one point and get the night
here something like that for example
it's a it's just equal in comparison
rook b8 here is stronger why exactly it
is very concrete again if white nor
place b3 securing the porn he has made a
huge blunder because rook c8 is stronger
now this rook see one coming winning the
rook on h1 and white has no way to
interpose as Bishop a for now is useless
as the b3 porn in the way so Luke c1 is
just just winning means that we will win
the B to Point and after something like
castles rugby to blacks initiative also
connected with night before we win am
yet another pawn and then it's even upon
up for black so Queens is six is not
helping at all which means that there is
only one move we have to take the night
yeah this is what Tim on did he took the
night Queen takes yeah and now we see
the point one point of the sacrifice
black screen is just in time on a six to
prevent castling it's really a matter of
one tempo if white would have castles
everything's fine he even would get a
super great night on deform yeah but
it's not happening you cannot cancel
white plate Queen a3 this is the best
defense and now again gala plays the
absolute best Museum he can actually
trade on a three and play would be 84
about equal play but it is much stronger
to play Queen to see for keeping the
Queen on the sensitive diagonal and
making sure that white
still cannot cancel this is a very very
difficult position to play especially
considering that we are in a in a
practical game and we're not yeah at
home yeah sitting there and nowadays
even with the computer where tells us
all the right stuff defending this over
the board is really brutal yeah mostly
two moves come into consideration Tim al
played King dattur and move that
definitely comes into consideration the
ideas to play rook c1 and get the
routine to play the other moves that I
think was quite logical was Queen c3
however after that black has a good
reply and again it's a matter of
precision the best move here is clearly
rugby ate a very strong move the idea is
we keep the position of the Queen intact
so white cannot castle we threaten to
take on c3 and flag queen bee one check
and you position the rook exactly on the
right term on the right um open file so
that we can enter on be too for example
after the capture we take with the pawn
and this changes the pawn structure very
much to blacks favor as a capture of the
beep on we gather give us a passer
immediately the relatively best defense
here would have been be three but after
this of course Black is just better he's
got the past a porn supported by a
bishop the long-range piece it is
nothing that you really want to play
it's just better for black yet Tippin
plate after Queen seaforth he played
King g2s mentioned and here again we see
how strong gala is playing the whole
game again here there is only one move
that keeps the initiative going
everything else passes over the the
whole cause of the game
too black to white I'm sorry yeah
allowing stuff like Roxy one or 94 Roxy
one later it's simply not not enough
especially 94 is a problem which sort of
limits then the black queen the best
move by far is the move played by Geller
twin g4 just very strong it attacks the
pawn just as that and how is right going
to defend it you cannot give up the pawn
I mean it totally screws up White's
coordination if you give it up for
example I mean let's say rook see one
just to look at it we take and
immediately attack those crucial spots
on f2 and f3 and this is of course a
deadly pen yeah it is very much clear
that white only has one reply he has to
play absolutely play king rook rook g1
it's the only way to defend stuff like
kingly to for example where you sort of
offer the e to pawn it's not the I'm
punished by capturing the pawn but with
the introduction of a new attacking
piece with rook c8 yeah note that the
King on you too it's not allowing rook
see one anymore and this is very very
strong yeah there's also the additional
idea to play d4 and Bishop c4 check this
attack is decisive the only way to put
up some defense is really what Tamar
played after Queen g-form he played the
rook g1 passive looking but it is the
only move that keeps the game going and
now again a series of super strong moves
by geller Black now has only one move
again to keep the whole thing going and
this is key for
yeah very very strong that the
breakthrough on this key square on
deform yeah what is the point white can
capture it with the pawn or with the
night if white captures with the pawn
this has some very important
consequences black now all of a song has
got a great Bishop it's not limited by
the d5 point anymore and the bishop has
various ideas it can go to sea floor at
the right moment or sometimes so d5
putting pressure here whoops on a three
and still on this side of the board and
there is an additional idea sometimes
also is this check here after the
poorness switch to the default square
there is this f 4 square is available
yeah I hope how can it continue what is
the concrete way to continue on and this
is a good move for example rook c8
getting the rook on the Open File very
very tough to defend if white now place
I mean it's difficult to really give
white them any advice if you play
something like b3 for example yeah
trying to prepare wuxi one let's say um
black will have fun and decisive attack
already check king you 1 and Bishop g4
yeah and you cannot defend this Bishop
takes a three idea plus this this this
threat it's a super strong attack that
is basically not defendable yeah Knight
takes default is better what Simon plate
and it's not that obvious I think
beforehand to see what black is doing
now what is playing is simply queen edge
form and this is a double attack on this
bone and this point and if one of the
points yeah for there is a direct attack
on the rook and the porn on g2 so the
whole King side is crumbling note that
the white queen is offside typical
scenario if the white queen I mean this
is just fantasy but would be lets say on
the Kings
somewhere there is no attack whatsoever
this is just possible because the queen
is in a bad spot on a three and black
simply has to the initiative with all of
those moves Queen g4 d for just very
very strong yeah now as mentioned those
two pawns are hanging what is what is it
that white should do he played rupee one
which is a good defense I'm the
alternative kingi one wasn't helping
really um black has more than one would
move now but very strong as rook c8
intending wuxi one and after b3 again a
very strong move looks to see three what
is the big point the point is that if
white now takes we have this very funny
check due to this pin and after a king
move rook takes we have a decisive
attack as black yeah this is just like
would be quite okay if those pieces
would would switch their places like a
late castles but this way um this is not
defendable at all white if white
snatches the pawn there is queenie for
with the designs of attack that's no
defense IAM kenya one is not doing the
trick i think relatively speaking
terrence move was quite good this rookie
one move yeah here after rookie one we
come to the only situation where gala is
playing the second best move in the
whole game um he now played quinta x f2
which is totally apparent yeah and it
obviously smooth however if we look at
this in in detail and of course nowadays
we can check this with an engine um
Bishop c4 is even stronger it seems
which could pass the capture white
really does not have any great reply to
that he can try something like f3 and
probably should try something like a
three after which the check and bishop
everyone is better for black
but it's not an immediate win black is
better but it's not an immediate win
still this is a little bit more
convincing than in the game in the game
after the capture on f2 what what gala
played after rookie to Queen moves and
night xe6 it was helpful from white that
the night could actually take the bishop
the bishop was a strong attacking peace
and in general of course trades very
often favored the defenders there are
less attacking pieces it is quite
surprising that after 96 fe and queen d6
there does not seem to be a winning
attack for black anymore it is I mean it
you never had a winning attack but they
had a very very dangerous attack after
Bishop c4 think black is better but here
it seems that while the position is
super super difficult to defend for
white from a purely objective point of
view or let's say from mathematical
point of view um the the whole thing is
it's not not decisive at all and
practically speaking this is a terrible
position for white but just drama from
analytically from an analytical point of
view it is not that clear black played
King edge 8 which is good yeah you want
to get out of the check only six and now
a form of course why cannot play this or
leave the default because then the rook
enters the whole scenario with the size
of effect efore is just the best move it
also makes some rooms on the king rook
c8 and King III that is the right the
right we are getting the King out of it
rook f8 rookie evade is a strong move I
think the idea is to play Queen g1 check
and then enter on f1 so that both pieces
actually joined the attack
white or ever now I think could have put
up very very stern defense with the
movie 5 and looks that you didn't play
after you five it seems that it seems
that black is not not winning or having
an advantage however I must admit that
my analysis is certainly not totally
conclusive as it all has limits and in
terms of time that you that you can
invest something like the check here
rook c8 is still looking very dangerous
but I mean I and the computer couldn't
find something decisive white sometimes
manages to get the king over to g2 to
the event flaxton as an initiative in a
way and it's easier to play but does not
seem to be winning outright 'if i've
probably what's the better defense or
not probably quite surely the better
defense but it is very very difficult to
play playing with such a wii king is
never much fun and especially in a
limited time situation in a practical
game terrible terrible to play Tim on
played the move rookie to group t2 and
now again a strong least by gala keeping
the initiative alive he played the movie
5 this is strong yeah why exactly it is
strong because white cannot take the
pawn we would see this in the game he
took it which is a mistake but it cannot
take the pawn and it gives black
additional ideas it takes those two
squares away d 4 in their form and it
gives those ideas um yeah a little bit
more bite in general like he needs to
use some yeah all of his units to to to
keep the attack going there are some
very interesting lines that you can find
if you dig a little bit deeper after you
five as mentioned Tim I took only five
which turns out to be the
decisive mistake after that black
definitely wins and Gellar does an
impeccable job of actually winning the
game after that um what else is there I
mean let's say rook seat to wear white
is just waiting what is a way for black
forward I know it looks terrible like
there should be some series of checks
and then then yeah winning it's not
there it's really not them if you find
something conclusive would be great but
I mean Houdini stockfish whatever and me
we didn't find anything but black in
fact has interesting ways forward I was
very much fascinated by the fact that
after Luke see to the engines give a
five as the best move at first I
couldn't really figure out what what
what does this move a 5-1 it is it doing
in fact it has a very nice idea that
idea is to push all the way to a three
and by dislodging this be to pond to
gain new inroads into whites position
yeah ideas could be let's say when the
rook has left the C file there could be
rook c8 rooks III looks a bit yet now i
have a through here but let's say just
for example we do something like that
and then this type of idea it's very
dangerous or rook b8 sometimes when the
queen is not on d6 what you basically
want opened as much the position is
possible and find new entry squares for
the pieces it is quite funny that after
a five the comp wants to play a for you
have to stop the pawn and then the the
next suggestion is actually to go with
the h pawn and try the same thing on the
other side you are trying to get rid of
this Jeep on and then ultimately invade
on f3 that's really remarkable and in
its itself it's a well-known fact that
very often pushing the flank points can
be an attacking device to gain squares
near the king but this is really a funny
case with this kind of simplified
position where lots of pieces are traded
that you can actually play stuff like
that even aged five in front of your own
king but it is very very dangerous for
wide and and very tough to defend and I
couldn't really bring it to a conclusion
like black wins or what whatever it's
probably better for black but hard to
tell if he if he can win um definitely
with e five earlier there was a better
defense for 41 but ok let's go back to
the critical position after if I he
didn't play one of the waiting moves
like like a three rook situ or whatnot
he played Queen takes d5 and after that
finally Black has a winning position get
up late the check and now we see where
the problem is if King III there's a
simple move up yet that's not possible
so they're only is rookie 2 and now
after the check King III the rook comes
to the default was decisive effect the
problem that we had all the time in the
last couple of moves that we couldn't
get both pieces into the tech now as
solved both rook and queen iron the
attack King c3 and now again a good move
rook kingdom king king roc no Queen
Queen d1 queen d 1 is the the best move
now edit text the rook and that prepares
rook c8 when the King really has to go
for a walk there is no defense now white
plate Queen to be five check King c2 and
now the final little stroke more than
one way now to win but the solution
plate buying gala is very
straightforward you played the move a
six attacking the Queen and the Queen
also has to take care of this queen bee
three thing so um something like in
let's say queen bee seven it's not
possible we just do this and when the
same 21 mate coming so basically white
can only take it there is nothing else
and he played that after Queen takes a
six there was only one more move in the
game Quincy five check and here Timmon
resigned after King b1 the rishta direct
made alternatively here this check with
a mate on before coming shortly so a
game that I always liked very much it
always fascinated me how geller managed
to keep this initiative going from a
position where it seems that there's
only like one move than wide leads but
he someone never gets to it this kind of
position here really found fascinating
because if you look at this after the
trade it really looks like okay okay you
cannot castle true but isn't this very
bad bishop yeah this Bishop is just
staring at his own porn how is this
going to participate in the game in the
tech and it was just so great to witness
how the series of strong moves actually
with the big point D for managed to get
everything into the attack yeah the
bishop is well all of a sudden Knight
takes e4 and now after Queen age for
rookie one it would have been great if
gala actually would have found Bishop c4
which is keeping the bishop on the board
as an attacking piece this is the only
slight flaw in display after Queen takes
f to it seems that timin from a
theoretical point of view could have
defended but we shouldn't forget this is
some game played by by human beings
where you shouldn't really take an
evaluation of the computer of 000 as an
indication that it is a simple draw it
isn't white in this game always had the
more difficult task to solve note that
with this king it's never fun not at all
you're always walking a tightrope trying
to defend
against all attacking ideas that that
that get thrown get thrown at you so um
yeah I think from a practical point of
view this is a very very difficult
position for for Tim on to play it
ultimately he stumbled and and lost the
game yeah I hope you you like this um if
you enjoyed this game by geller look at
someone he has played a ton of great
games like this kind of very logical
attacking games with somehow sort of fit
together very well and not the kind of
attacking games where there are bubbles
out of the blue or some let's say fishy
sacrifice and some are there working it
sort of makes lots of sense of tees
doing some out of course there are
defenses here and there but he's a very
often managed to build up pressure and
in a very logical end and sort of
classical sort of way yeah hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching